the question is what does truth mean in
fiction because of course the first the
first premise of fiction is that it's
not true you know that this story does
not record events that took place these
people didn't exist these things did not
happen you know I mean that's that's the
going in point the point of a novel so
it's the novel tells you flat-out
at the beginning that it's untruthful
you know but then so what do we mean
then by truth in literature and clearly
what we mean is is human truth not not
photographic journalistic recorded truth
but the truth we recognize as human
beings about about how we are with each
other you know how we deal with each
other what are our strengths and our
weaknesses how we interact and what is
that what is the meaning of our lives
you know I mean this is this is what we
look at you know you don't need to know
that Anna Karenina really existed you
know we need to know who she is what
moves her and what and and what her
story tells us about our own lives and
about ourselves you know and that's what
that's the kind of truth that as readers
we look for and in in literature now
once you accept that stories are not
true once you start from that position
then you understand that a flying carpet
and Madame Bovary are untrue in the same
way you know and as a result both of
them are ways of arriving at the truth
by the road of untruth and so that they
can both do it the same way I mean this
is the first novel in which I've
actually managed finally to include a
flying carpet not really
I've been wanting to do it for a long
time and and the immediate thing that I
thought the moment you decide you're
going to have a rug that flies through
the air is you must immediately ask
yourself realistic questions about it
what would that be like you know if you
were standing on a carpet and it
levitated would it be difficult to keep
your balance would the carpet be rigid
or with the movement of the air under
the carpet make the carpet
undulate
you know if you flew very high wouldn't
it get very cold how would you kill how
you keep warm on a flying carpet and I
think the moment you start asking
yourself those kind of practical real
world questions the flying carpet
becomes believable you know it becomes a
thing that might exist and if it existed
it would function like this but in the
end what you're looking for in this book
a fairy tale of fable and allegory a
fantasy is the same thing you're looking
for in you know in kind of kitchen-sink
realism you're looking for people that
you can believe in behaving in ways that
you can recognize and and which tell you
something those those behaviors tell you
something about your own behavior in
your own nature and about the life of
the person next door to you as well you
know so human truth is what you're
looking for and you could get to that by
many different roads